previously on phasmophobia
let's get this ghost oh i heard it for
handprints
we can't get out we can't get up oh
i can't open the door won't open oh okay
yeah we saw it there's a ghost here
mystery solved all right let's go
[Music]
open the pocket front door are we
confident it's a wraith
well did you get temperature readings i
didn't get any low ones
i can go put the journal down do you
guys want me to do that as well
that is the funniest kid i've ever heard
he's dead right oh he's dead yeah
there's a camera laying at the bottom of
the floor
hey let's get this to get out of here
i'm glad they find my death
so hilarious wait can you hear me
no holy [ __ ] that was amazing
for you mark i can't hear you i'm glad
you're
scared you found my death so hilarious
yeah no we walked up to the front door
and it was locked and we can just hear
you upstairs scream
yeah i was running for my life to the
front door and it was just locked and
yeah
mm-hmm all i hear is laughter once i get
up
yeah i'm level two i'm way better than
you idiots so did you guys put wraith
was it a race
i think it was a spirit i put wraith it
didn't well i was dead so what does it
matter
that was a great death mark thank you
yeah thank you thank you
i'm gonna go i just about vomited up my
lungs there
yeah i my throat hurt laughing so
happy for you guys listen mark not at
you
right now we don't have a thermometer
anymore
um do we need to buy it again oh you
know what i'm going to select a
different job because
we need to get one of these right we
really got to get one of these
all of our options require a thermometer
okay well i bought one
so i'll add it to the pile okay just go
ahead and add that make sure you guys
add your flashlights if you still have
flashlights i got i can't
none i lost everything by dying that
time apparently yeah i got nothing man
wait wait i have a thermometer i still
own all my stuff i i have my one
flashlight my crucifix and my
thermometer dude
i got nothing man you die you lose
everything yeah apparently
thank god i haven't died yet it's a load
off what was that
what i don't know did you i heard it
[Music]
this is not where the ghosts are calm
down is this a save no you guys heard
that
right okay oh okay never mind then okay
we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine it's all fine
listen you die to a wraith spirit
monster geist and all of a sudden life
changes okay
apparently it does apparently it does we
could have saved our
lives pulled out a crucifix or smudge
stick while we were doing that
do we need a lighter if we're gonna
bring smudge sticks i think we've done a
lighter probably yeah
also um i was told that apparently if we
walk around holding the camera
somebody can stay on the trailer and
look and you can as long as the green
light's on
you don't have to place the camera you
can walk around with it somebody can
watch that's andy well who's gonna be
radio man i feel like i did an excellent
job with it
i think so too you didn't die yeah i'm
the only one of us who hasn't died so
far
i'm sure that won't come back to bite me
this round it's fun give it a shot
that's why i'm level two that's probably
it
okay all right charles davis
i would like to be thermo man this round
there mama man
charles davis seems to respond to
everyone you should be able to use its
name and anger
ooh get its name in anger guys we could
talk
mad [ __ ] about this dude no that's
because that's been the same every time
it always says oh okay you came in the
anger emf reader
thermometer we need to find a room below
10 celsius yes
gotcha i'm thermo man this round
i did grab the crucifix is anyone on
spirit box do you guys want me to do it
um someone needs spirit boxes uh someone
grab this camera too maybe
i'll do i'll do the camera too i was
just trying not to grab too much someone
wait why don't you read the spirit box
her mark okay
i couldn't i got the email i'm gonna
bring the journal so i got that
so we're all good here okay we should
just go ahead and do some recon and then
come back out and get some much sticks
and [ __ ]
let's do it baby i'm gonna stay here
whoever has the camera
walk around with the camera and the
light on camera okay
camera working wade camera's working
hi i'm going upstairs but i have the
thermometer too don't we need to find a
cold room
yeah we need to find a cold spot too
cold in the kitchen cold spot in the
kitchen
tennessee roger that coming down
for you are we definitely journaling
freezing temperatures
oh we got hand print on the door we got
hand
somebody said prints 10 degrees does not
count as freezing it has to be like
blues
i see 4.8 4.8
in the door
okay yeah i called that out but you oh
yeah let's just let everyone else get
the credit
can they hear the journal i have the
journal
book is down charles davis are you here
3.6 1.7 c
0 is freezing right yes we're at 1
degree celsius on the book right now
charles davis give us a sign i'm gonna
come in with ems
temperatures all right freezing
temperatures oh yeah i can see my breath
yeah it's freezing it's either race or
banshee so far
took a picture nothing a banshee is a
natural hunter will attack anything it's
been known to stalk its prey one in time
till making its kill
fancy will only target one person at a
time and she's fear the crucifex and
will be less aggressive near one
okay i'll go get a crucifix here can you
uh i was told that you can take a
picture of the hammer
and chuck it yeah take a picture of it
got you oh it didn't take like a uv
picture though oh weird i don't know if
that worked
okay that's fine oh it counted
wait pick up that smudge stick okay put
it to my fire
this doesn't feel right you have to
place the smudge stick down and then
light it
like set it down and light it oh wait
drop it and press f with the lighter
okay these cabinets just opened right
here these cabinets are moving it's not
working
oh there it is it's lit it's lit
oh it is working these cabinets just
opened right here i don't know what to
do with this crucifix i'm trying to play
i can't place it i can't really do much
with it i think you just hold it up
oh davis i don't think spirit box will
work because the other three did
that would be a different thing let me
go check the truck to see if you
cleansed it let me see
let's all go back to the truck together
real quick uh looks like it has been
cleansed yes
is there anything we haven't done if we
wanted to if we want to do the crucifix
i think we got to get it to attack first
someone's telling me to throw the
crucifix on the floor
give it a try i'm gonna go back in oh
where i'll go back was it a banshee
yes yeah definitely emf went to five at
one point yeah
[Music]
it doesn't say the objective was
completed but i i count that as a win
[ __ ] yeah we didn't prevent it from
hunting
all right that's good yeah i think we
got we know what it is
that's all we need to know what if we
try and get a picture of it
i have like one picture left i don't
think so
yeah i don't think so i can go try to
grab it
you have a crucifix yeah he grabbed it
yeah i picked it back up off the floor i
said that
oh yeah then we everyone okay we could
we could try if you guys want
no
money baby level two level two
hell yeah what else should we buy i mean
we should just keep uh adding to our
stash right
yeah we got one video can't we got like
one of everything at least
yeah i think that's good
chat's saying if we take pictures of
bones and fingerprints and stuff it
gives you bonus money that does make
sense it
it would be more evidence and stuff all
right i want to bring the book
i've got a i've got the writing book
i'll be the radio guy
we need a picture of dirty water in a
sink interesting
evidence of paranormal with emf and then
witness a ghost event so uh
all right sandra williams we've been
pretty good at that sandra williams
sandra williams are you ready hello you
need to be alone for this one
okay so we should spread out yeah spread
it out bob you have to
wait outside the room yeah i have the
camera it's on okay
i'm gonna watch from here of course you
are
oh this is the first house again yeah
back here
sandra williams are you there
nothing detected i found a bone do we
need a picture of this bone or should i
just pick it up
i i can go take a picture of the bone
but i think you need the other camera
not the video yeah i got the camera i'm
coming get you some bone evidence
i haven't seen anything yet you know
what i mean
nice nice bone shot sick mark can you
get that picture of dirty water in a
sink yet
uh no i'll go back to the kitchen see if
i can get that i think you can actually
turn
on water so if the sinks are empty turn
the faucet on and see if dirty water
comes out
roger that is that
all right we got clear water upstairs we
got
clear water in the kitchen maybe leaving
the water maybe it'll get dirty
okay and you never let the water run
good call good call you right
we're not killing the planet i like that
we could hear each other quietly off the
radio he's like
all right
are you here
is anyone there
is anyone in here
i'm not getting anything is anyone there
are some spikes in activity are we just
missing them
they're not they're not even turning the
lights off in here oh hand print never
mind we got a reading
okay uh it's uh
towards where it's the laundry room you
guys know the laundry room is anyone
here
i'm over in the laundry room right here
there's a hand print and there actually
there's a fingerprint on the
there's a fingerprint on the light
switch here too i didn't know that oh
yeah i saw that
i wonder if i could take a picture of
that prince for number one
emf not giving me anything yeah so far
just handprints
sandra williams
[Music]
yeah and the lights just went out too it
might be over there
uh follow me if you can see me i cannot
it's only a two do not mark emf
it's only a two way where am i i got
lost
anyone see him i see you okay you're in
here yeah hello she's gone
oh oh okay is anyone there one other
section for the house
yeah geez this is a big ass house sandra
williams sandra you got a big ass house
williams um here's the camera i'll go
watch the camera again
the camera is set up oh three degrees
three degrees three
oh nice cold cold sandra williams it's a
back up to
oh four degrees show yourself i'm
leaving wait we should leave we should
spread out yeah yeah
will do still nothing on uh the spirit
box i'm thinking this is a big negative
on the spirit box
yeah i'm gonna drop the spirit box back
off the truck
wait writing in the book writing in the
book writing in the book writing in the
book
spirit with spirit or revenant yeah
revenants are fast and if you hide from
it it'll move very slowly
there would be an emf 5 if it's a
revenant so i need to come back in and
try to find the mf5
it's either gonna be spirit box or emf
reader we're gonna have to keep trying
spirit box and emf reader those are our
two indications of which one it is i
went in like every room with that spirit
box
where was the writing yeah no mark go
back go back in the back bedroom by the
uh
by the by the circuit breaker oh my god
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait i gotta
be driving i don't have anything i don't
have anything
oh my god i got a picture of it i got a
picture of it
and my flashlight won't work happening i
got a picture of it i've got a crucifix
where are you guys in it
we're we're fine yeah right there we're
here right right
holy [ __ ] i thought we were dead well we
should have witnessed the ghost event
then right
yeah one of the things yeah yeah yeah
all right we have two objectives caught
off check that room for the dirty water
the one with the
writing in it i hear you sorry i didn't
radio i'm going to check dirty water
you got nothing in the spirit box right
i mean nothing immediately but
maybe i can go back and get it we're all
grouped up again i don't know
do i have to be alone to get the emf
reading
five got five five five we got a five
five we got it get out get out
yeah that's a revenue yeah i don't think
we should mess with the revenant all
right
am i fine from apex right all right
sean what happened
is he dead
oh no wait can we do something crucifix
burn some sage
doors open sean bob we're gonna
we gotta go we gotta go guys
don't don't hold on let's all make sure
we have revenant in our book
oh that's right we've got revenant in
their book yeah i got revenant down
yep we missed the dirty water we got
everything else though that's fine you
know that's fine
just a shame when you're god on the way
out it got him that's
it did it like lock the door or
something literally he was right behind
us
it closed the door in his face and then
everything started freaking out
and always could hear the door oh no oh
that's a shame yeah hate to see it
yeah i hate to see it all right you guys
good yeah we're good well they're
successful
another banger of a mission yep another
success we just lost shawn again
another winner welcome back i've
prepared some jobs for you oh yeah look
at that
money oh level three hell yeah
i turned around for a split second and
was like oh wait the journal and when i
turn back to you guys
oh no i already had the journal in my
head oh no i don't think we have to grab
the item
i think we keep them as long as we live
oh [ __ ] oh my gosh
level three ah sean we had the exact
same ex
so wait that was what we heard when mark
died the other time
we could we could see you through the
window and it was just
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i can't select a job
right now wait am i in charge gary i'm
in charge
i don't know what have we done we've
done edgefield street house we've done
they all kind of changed they've all all
the ones we've done have been amateur if
there's any that are higher than
anything let's do
brownstone high school um
that sounds cool right recommended item
sanity pills
location size medium shut down due to
unnatural desks this isolated school has
been abandoned for decades the owner
called this morning
from what he said it sounds like a
dangerous week haunting the area
well you can't get so many builders we
need to be level we'd be level five to
buy them that's fine we don't need them
we'll be fine let's just do it is this
still amateur bob or there's a higher
difficulty
it's that amateur it's still an amateur
okay all right it's a new place though
it's nice i kind of want to try the
better flashlight
oh is that level three good idea um
but yeah well maybe you can buy it and
add it and then the lower level could
still use it
wait what is an infrared light sensor do
we have that
a parabolic microphone oh
those are good [ __ ] in here okay so just
let's not all die
yeah oh god oh god
don't you walk crotch first towards mark
that's that's not appropriate
hey what's up pretty lady i think
they're strong
i think the strong flashlights are down
below yeah i didn't i just had a reggoe
there are 15 cameras already in this
place
holy geez the objectives discover what
type of ghost
find evidence of the paranormal with an
emf reader
i gotta cleanse the area using smudgeos
we do we have any smudgeos
uh have a member of your team i've
witnessed a ghost event this place
is huge michael thomas
michael everybody thomas responds to
everyone use its name to anger it
i don't know if we need the camera
someone grab a journal maybe
yeah someone grabbed mark's got stories
i'll take a smudge
and a and a lighter i guess oh this
looks fun
oh yeah oh yeah oh my god
oh yeah oh hell yeah boys
oh this is cool this looks good this is
way bigger than the last place
yeah if we're [ __ ] well who knows
maybe it's blocked off inside
i think the talkies the walkie-talkies
are going to be crucial
yeah maybe a little bit and i'm going to
go back i'm going to look where the fuse
box is because we're going to need to
know that
oh we're boned we're bone guys we're
boned
we might be mega boned the fuse box is
on the second
floor from the entrance side looks like
the left side of the school
it's towards the back left on the second
floor
okay we're [ __ ] then because this
place is massive yes it is
um i'm checking the cameras real quick
just to give you a bird's eye
this is terrifying jesus christ
all this for like maybe 50 bucks okay
all right all the cameras look
clear okay roger 10-4
what are you guys doing up there
why my god where are you i'm downstairs
yeah we're downstairs in the right we're
in the right wing we went through the
basketball we're in the class
oh i see you guys why are you guys not
turning on lights
i don't i didn't realize oh hey that
there were lights yeah the lights
it's a school but what if the circuit
breaker flips well
that's why i looked where it was okay
i'm getting nothing
there's no temperature difference this
place is too big not seen anything
upstairs yet
we just need to yell this asshole's name
until he comes to
us michael thomas michael thomas is so
stupid
michael thomas you're an idiot nothing
on emf yet
did the lights go for anyone else did
the future
i think feels just blue this place is
too big
this place is way too big
yes [ __ ] i mean michael thomas
hey michael i bet you can't kick my
ass you guys hearing a bit of a
phenomenon
over in the first floor bottom back left
yeah what is that sean come here come
here
yeah you guys hearing that can you hear
me yeah mark what is that i don't know i
i checked i'm gonna go turn the lights
on but man that's
wait wait come back to the come back to
the hallway
okay yeah let's explore in the rooms up
here
uh mars mark hopefully we'll get the
lights on in a sec i'm
working on it take your time buddy we
got your back it's okay
i mean wait you guys are right here
where it is
it's in one it's right here
no we're here in the trickle yeah well
we were on the other side of the wall i
think
yeah wait what is thomas are you here
is it the drinking fountains oh it's in
here dirty water we got dirty water it's
a faucet it's a faucet
oh
five degrees six degrees in here yeah
three degrees michael thomas
i see nothing got a four nine four on
the ems who is the turtle
who is the journal oh wait i do i do
michael thomas give us a sign
oh wait the journal's written in my hand
says die die die die die
okay so we got right now okay excellent
he wrote in
seeing nothing uh let me look let me
look let me look onis are cousin of the
demon possessed extreme strength there
have been rumors they become more active
around their prey
uh owners are more active when people
are nearby have been seen moving
objects at great speed emf spear box and
ghost writing so emf five would be an
oni
demon would be freezing temperatures uh
demonstration questions on the ouija
board won't lower users standing demons
will attack more often than any other
ghost
bobbins on you the emf is on you oh cool
cool we're not we're not getting
freezing temperatures so i don't think
it's that
michael thomas michael freezing
temperatures fingerprints or what was
the other one
uh mf5 emf5
we just got emf5 now no no no no we
haven't done
hate adult mark he said hey any
fingerprints i know anything i haven't
seen anything he's a kid he hates adults
he wants to rebel against school
oh enough four in the doorway
michael why do you hate adults
okay okay time to go time to go uh yeah
time to go i'm gonna smudge him
i'm gonna smudge him smudge away he was
right there in that doorway
fudging smudging smudging smudging
smudging smudging the door who closed
the door
holy jesus i did not close the door i
grabbed the crucifix and the door closed
i thought you were dead
all right we go we go we go we go let's
go to the truck let's go to the truck
let's get to the truck okay he's an oni
he's an owning definitely oni
michael thomas is an oni so we do what's
up boys let's just take the money and
get out
i like being in the back you shouldn't
have been so slow then
yeah it's not like anything bad has
happened to the last person through the
doorway
michael thomas michael thomas michael
thomas michael thomas michael thomas
michael thomas
michael thomas michael thomas michael
thomas michael thomas michael thomas
michael thomas
michael thomas ah he made it
yeah i closed it uh michael thomas is a
big oh
[ __ ] look we got all of them please
oh hello make sure you got oni
in your journal make sure yeah do your
journal yeah we got spirit box ghost
writing and emf and the ghost type is
oni yeah
i thought bob was dead i thought
you closed the door on me what are you
no no i grabbed your crucifix and the
door closed i didn't close
we didn't get any insurance yeah wait is
insurance life insurance
is that what happens if someone dies do
we get the insurance
no insurance oh you got the lady in the
doorway that's so cool i know right
bottom right oh you got a picture of oh
[ __ ] dude that's a good one that's a
keeper
oh it's different for me i don't know
what you guys are seeing where it
which one is it you have to get really
the picture is for me
in the door for me it's top left but
yeah there she is uh bob are you still
in charge of uh
no i am those two harder ones let's do
it boys is there anything higher than
amateur
no we can go to brownstone high school
grafton farmhouse or edgefield street
house
whichever whichever one you you guys
want to do all right let's go back to
the school that was cool
we got to keep leveling up to get higher
difficulties apparently okay give leave
me a strong flashlight this time i'm
tired of
wandering like that 145
we're rich he was hiding in the girls
bathroom
yeah weirdo weirdo that is pretty that's
a pretty creepy place to hang out that
is pretty weird now
we didn't die in that huge place none of
us died yeah we're pretty surprised
how much of a miracle that is all right
i know we need a photo of the ghost
thermometer all right i want to be emf
man
i got a photo camera and an emf yeah
mark you've been pretty good with the
camera so
maybe yeah i'm the photographer i
brought in some extra photo
all right well i'll do i'll get a
picture of their feet you can take a
camera too if you want it you go
no no no no no no
we probably should have two cameras just
get more evidence and money i love
money well i just want to make sure we
have all the tools so i'm i have emf and
journal right now
wade's gonna wade could have a camera
wait could take a camera and a
flashlight and
something else he's a deterrent yeah we
should probably have a cruise fix or a
smudger or something
elizabeth miller i'm gonna need your
boys to say it elizabeth miller
elizabeth miller elizabeth miller why
did we need to be together
uh because it angers it more oh shows up
better oh man having a having a
flashlight is nice
why does the emf reader look like
something you open your garage door with
it's like a little basically the same as
like don't go there we've done this bit
before
any bit regarding my accent just has
been done to death don't you guys make
fun of me for saying tutorial all the
time
yeah well you don't have an accent
you're just an idiot okay that's
that's proven false comparing yourself
to ethan should not make you feel less
like an idiot
all right fair enough listen that was a
little personal
i'm sorry mark and no i i i'm i'm not
hurt
mark i just want to make sure you can
hear me yeah i'm sorry i pointed out a
fact about you
yeah it's fine piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
doesn't even know how to use a radio
yeah i'm using it now can't you guys
hear me
yeah and you cut it off a little early
there and you didn't say over oh well
you didn't say over there
either over over mark flash me is that
you in the distance
keep that out i got amf it's on
constantly
yeah bob's got bob's got it over oh it
does cut off early you know what mark
it's not your fault that the radio was
cutting you off thank you
you know it's it's the elements setting
us against each other
really getting inside my head it's
making me
i angry took a dna test turns out
you're 100 dead you took a dna
test to prove that she was dead you
could have had a dead
[ __ ] it's a reference wade mark thank
you for separating from them i'm sorry i
made fun of you no it's okay man
listen i get it i i knew the truth what
what's up
are you guys idiots or ghosts they're
idiots i mean they're idiots sorry
mark now that we're alone those guys are
really holding us back
that's what i was saying is always
saying why do we got to split the pot
four ways when it's both of us doing all
the work
all right guys you gotta let go of the
button guys uh that's a 10-4 on my hurt
feelings over
roger that okay guys get a little
personal
uh over okay
thank you apparently there's a backyard
over
i'm not moving uh
i heard footsteps what i stopped moving
and there were more footsteps
was it me coming out no it was on the
ground out here
unless those are some crunchy steps oh
yeah i know it is crunchy huh
i have a feeling she won't be out here
eh maybe
the school is haunted not the yard well
i don't know it's all part of the school
school yard thank you bob my only basis
is the creepy atmosphere once we walk
through the tower
all right it's that's fair that's fair
oh there's a fuse box oh it's another
one
oh that's really handy elizabeth
i'm at 11 degrees 12 degrees oh good i
don't think that's an exit
elizabeth we're hearing something
oh never mind then i'm ready to snap a
sweet phone whoa
classroom is this elizabeth miller
reminds me like a church from outlast or
something i don't like this room at all
elizabeth miller bob
bob
ah
[Music]
foreign